[Applause]
in this video we'll talk about the CSF
profile analysis for the meningitis this
is a high yield video for USMLE step 1.
so what is meningitis meningitis simply
means the inflammation of the meninges
so here is the skull just for your
orientation underneath that there would
be durometer arachnoid matter and
parameter which are different parts of
the meninges and the overall
inflammation of the meninges is known as
meningitis
meningitis can be caused due to many
reason but just to give you an idea this
is how a normal and infected meninges
look like
and the reason for meningitis could be
bacterial there are bacterias like
streptococcus pneumonia this area
meningitis listeria monocytogenes
hemophilus influenzy can possibly lead
to bacterial meningitis there are
viruses which can cause meningitis like
Coxsackievirus like herpes virus like
HIV virus Etc
there could be also fungal meningitis
which is caused by different types of
fungus like cryptococcus and cocciditis
then there is parasitic meningitis which
can be caused by tapeworm and plasmodium
falciparum so these are a bit rare
compared to the other format of
meningitis but anyway whatever may be
the format the question is how does a
clinician would know that what is the
causal infect agent behind this
meningitis because each of the case
there would be an inflammation in the
meninges
so in order to do that a clinician would
look at the CSF profile of the patient
so after lumbar puncture CSF is
collected and that CSF is tested for by
biochemical components which we would
look into much more details
so CSF profile is very important for
understanding many disease and its
pathology
so normally CSF has this composition it
has very less amount of protein
substantial amount of glucose
and and different concentration of
different ions like chloride calcium
magnesium and potassium
but also it's very important to note
that lymphocytes are very less like
there are only like about five or even
less than five cells
per cubic millimeter
now the question is what really happens
when there is an infection so we would
try to understand
these in context of appearance of the
CSF opening pressure WBC count protein
content and glucose level
so in case of control it would be a
clear fluid but when there is a
bacterial meningitis there is turbid
turbid fluid in the uh in this scenario
then the protein level for all kind of
meningite meningitis the protein level
would be increased because the blood CSF
barrier and the blood brain barriers are
kind of compromised so some amount of
protein leaks in and it increases the
amount of protein in the CSF
then there is overall WBC count it has
to be very less if there is more amount
of WBC in the CSF then there is some
kind of infection now if mostly there
are neutrophils then must it might be
bacterial if mostly they are lymphocyte
then it might be viral
also glucose level utilization in the
many many in in the overall CSF is
really important because bacteria can
utilize a lot of glucose and that's why
in case of bacterial meningitis the
glucose level would be very low in CSF
also in case of fungal meningitis the
level is also low
and the opening pressure differences are
also one of the factor to cross check
for example elevated level of opening
pressure means bacteria most likely
bacterial meningitis so how does a
clinician proceed with all this data
so they ask is there an infection if
there is an infection there would be
more wbcs in the CSF right in all and
also there would be elevated level of
protein be it any kind of meningitis if
these two answers are no then there is
no infection
if these two answers are yes then the
clinician would check
what type of WBC is elevated is it pmn
or is it monocyte if it is pmn or
neutrophils then it would be most likely
bacterial meningitis or pyogenic
meningitis
if the WBC is comprised of mostly
monocytes then it might be a viral
meningitis
and what about the fungus in case of
fungal meningitis there is an increase
in monocytes also there is Hypoglycemia
that means a fair reduction in glucose
now it has to be understood that
reduction in glucose level is common for
both bacterial and fungal meningitis but
the cell type which is elevated here in
fungus is monocyte not neutrophils so
this is how a clinician could get a
broad idea that what type of infection
happened in case in in case of
meningitis and this kind of diagnosis
would help them to treat the condition
in a more efficient way I hope this was
useful if you want to get more flash
card and note visit our Facebook page
follow us on Instagram visit our website
all links are provided in the
description you can support our Channel
using PayPal paytm or UPI you can click
on the super thanks option to support us
and see you in next video